so being an individual you will have
your detractors either people who are
disagree with you or actually threatened
by you how do you handle them you see
norm accessible if you know you're doing
the right thing you're doing this in
your heart doesn't matter what other
people think if you're doing something
wrong and people are criticizing you
because you're acting you know
unethically morally that's different but
if you have people who aren't rooting
for you and I've seen this happen I've
seen a have a first-hand where people
are almost more comfortable with you
family and being unhappy being miserable
because you'll notice that when things
get good all of a sudden of people
disappear but that's okay surround
yourself with positive people now people
who necessarily tell you what you want
to hear but people who are positive in
who are more successful than you smarter
than you and people who embrace that
mentality because that's how you grow
but if you if you want to be the big
fish in a small pond well then there you
go there you'll be a big fish in a
puddle of mudd or I would rather be the
smallest fish in the best pot to the
biggest fish in a small pond what about
people who fear their social network
going away if they reach certain level
of success I I just don't think you
should spend any time worried about this
stuff you spend all your time worrying
about what can go wrong what other
people think what happens if technology
changes you don't even know tomorrow is
happening we're not guarantee that this
day isn't our last spend less time
worrying about what might happen focus
on what is that's the best way to move
forward
you